never done anything really stupid with
money
if you have that makes you over 12
almost all of us have my wife Sharon and
I started off with nothing when we first
got married most people do I think and I
start buying and selling real estate and
I got rich by the time I was 26 I was a
millionaire making 250,000 a year but
I'd done stupid
I borrowed too much money bank got sold
to another bank and some guilin of the
city looked down and said there's a kid
26 years old those as millions of
dollars let's limit this relationship
which is banker talk for ruin his life
they called our notes and we spent the
next two and a half years of our life
losing everything we owned we were sued
we were foreclosed on and finally we
were bankrupt I'd do everything
backwards I met God on the way up when I
was becoming wealthy most people meet
him at a point of crisis I met him on
the way up I got to know him on the way
down so twenty-eight years old with a
brand-new baby a toddler and a marriage
hanging on by a thread we got the
opportunity to start from zero again
only I had to figure out how money works
not what your broke brother-in-law's
opinion is how money really works and so
as a Christian I decided I would figure
out what the Bible has to say about
money and I talked to old rich people I
didn't want to talk to young rich people
I had been him I didn't want his opinion
in business we study successful people
in a certain area and then we emulate or
copy what they're doing in order to have
the same success they've had it's called
best practices that's why you hire a
personal trainer they have abs and you
have a keg they know something you don't
know they do something you don't do and
so we learn from someone that knows
something we don't know because they've
actually done it
not have a theory about it see I don't
really care what your theories are about
money if you're broke you're just
arrogant and stupid you live in your
mother's basement you write a money blog
and nobody cares what you think
they've rooms he doesn't understand the
power of credit cards oh my god really
after 30 years you're still writing this
stuff you've got to be kidding me
so we learned how to handle money and we
learned that money really is fairly
simple it's just hard to do there's only
about four or five things you got to do
to win if live on less than you make you
live on a plan written budget you need
to get out of debt because when you
don't have any payments you have money
your most powerful wealth building tool
is your income you've got to learn to
save and invest and you can't do that
when you're in debt don't have a plan
and don't live on less than you make you
know why people don't put money in their
401k and the Roth IRAs cuz they're gonna
be money because it's all going out the
door and stupid but car payments and
Sallie Mae's got her own bedroom at your
house cuz she's lived there for so long
this is pretty simple stuff guys
it may be primitive it may be easy to
understand but it is very hard to do
because it has everything to do with you
changing your heart and the way you
function and the way you live your life
and you live like no one else so that
later you can live and give like no one
else because that's the last one there's
a high correlation all of our data
between people who win with money and
those that are generous generosity is a
key element and people who end up
winning with money and it's pretty
simple it's because generous people are
attractive selfish people aren't they're
ugly
attractive people seem to get more
opportunities in life would you agree we
all want to help someone who's
attractive and
talking about physically attractive but
they're likable the person that holds
the door for you versus the one that
customs you for doing it
well helps you pick up your groceries
when they're rolling around the parking
lot because the bottom fell out of your
bag that's a generous person they might
be a person gives you some money because
you're broke you don't have money for
food or you're going through a hard time
and they help you out there's a high
correlation between generosity and
financial success and it's not that
financial success allows people to be
generous it's the generosity causes
people to be people that are lovable
likeable more than selfish people and
they have a tendency a prosper it's
pretty easy formula really if you think
about it and when you're out of debt the
room she doesn't understand the PO crow
decoys you out there watch the power of
credit cards destroy people's lives for
years I absolutely understand the power
of a credit card and I've watched stupid
people write clickbait articles about me
and other people saying how to use the
credit card the proper way to use a
credit card and credit cards are good
for reward points yeah I've never met a
millionaire that said Dave you know I
made all my money with airline miles
they those Discover points put me over
the top that was my breakthrough
financial moment never met a single
millionaire and I've met with thousands
of millionaires never met one that said
that we also I can't believe people's
fall apart fall for credit card debt I
can't believe people continue to use
these stupid credit cards it's like
somebody the half the population is
dying on lung cancer everybody stand
around going why I guess cigarettes kill
you well no kidding
unbelievable the credit card it's the
cigarette of the financial world used to
be cool everybody thought it was neat
and people are catching on that ain't a
good idea hello this is not rocket
science people live on less than you
make Becky's on Twitter do you literally
mean beans and rice or is that an
exaggeration to make a point
Becky you've got to be kidding me do you
really think people during this plant
only live on beans and rice I'm
really twits on twitter really of course
not it means lower you're stupid but
lifestyle and quit spending money like
you're in Congress is what it means it
means quit going out to eat you're broke
it means quit buying the most expensive
thing at whole paycheck over there and
and start why get your dadgum coupons
out and have a meal plan and actually
cook from scratch because it saves money
and go on vacation you're broke and
don't buy that you're broke you have
clothes in your closets stay out of the
mall live on less than you make that's
what it means if you live on less than
you make in order to pay off debt in
order to save and invest in order to be
generous you can't spend more than you
make and end up anywhere but in
bankruptcy court and people are doing it
everyday everywhere see this stuff we
teach your folks is not hard to
understand it's very hard to actually go
and do it this is the Dave Ramsey show